Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory, and we were the drug. The corruption of children, the mutilation of young men, the prostitution of women, the humiliation of the old, the division of the family, the division of the country. It had all been done in our name. People looked back to the French Saigon
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。要想每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory，我们当时就是毒品。毒害儿童、残害青年、凌辱妇女、羞辱老人、分裂家庭、分裂国家。这一切都是以我们的名义犯下的。人们带着一种对法属西贡的怀念，
with a sentimental warmth, as if the problem had begun with the Americans. But the French city, the Saigon of the Piastres, as Lucien Baudart called it, had represented the opium stage of the addiction, with the Americans had begun the heroin phase. And what I was seeing now was the first symptoms of withdrawal. That, Dominic, was James Fenton, who at the time was a young poet. So he's writing this in 1975. Is that right? No, he's writing this much later, but he was in Saigon. He went to Saigon in 1973. Yes, because he'd won a poetry prize, hadn't he? Won a poetry prize. He's the future professor of poetry at Oxford. He'd been at Oxford with Christopher Hitchens, because he'd won a poetry prize, hadn't he? Won a poetry prize. He's the future professor of poetry at Oxford. He'd been at Oxford with Christopher Hitchens and they'd shared a house in their third year.
仿佛问题是从美国人介入开始的。然而，正如吕西安·博达尔（Lucien Baudart）所称，法属城市——皮阿斯特（Piastres）的西贡——代表了这种瘾头中的鸦片阶段，而美国人则开启了海洛因阶段。我当时所看到的，正是戒断症状的初期。多米尼克，那是詹姆斯·芬顿（James Fenton），他当时还是一位年轻的诗人。所以他这是在1975年写的？对吗？不对，他写这篇东西要晚得多，但他在西贡。他于1973年去了西贡。是的，因为他赢得了诗歌奖，对吧？赢得了诗歌奖。他后来成为了牛津大学的诗歌教授。他曾与克里斯托弗·希租斯（Christopher Hitchens）一起在牛津念书，因为他赢得了诗歌奖，对吧？赢得了诗歌奖。他后来成为了牛津大学的诗歌教授。他曾与克里斯托弗·希租斯一起在牛津念书，并且在第三年合租过一栋房子。
That's right. So he goes out to see it and he's one of, I mean, lots of poets, writers, intellectuals, bohemians who are kind of attracted to this incredible spectacle, drama, tragedy of American involvement in Indochina. Yeah, exactly right. So not just Vietnam, but also Cambodia. And what Fenton is alluding to there with French Saigon and American Saigon, of course, is the great tragedy of the Vietnam War. So Vietnam had been part of French colonial possessions.
没错。所以他去那里亲眼目睹这一切，他可以说是那些被美国卷入印度支那的这场不可思议的奇观、戏剧和悲剧所吸引的众多诗人、作家、知识分子和波西米亚人之一。是的，完全正确。所以不仅是越南，还有柬埔寨。当然，芬顿在那里提到的法属西贡和美属西贡，正是越南战争的巨大悲剧。因此，越南曾是法国殖民地的一部分。
They'd been defeated at the Battle of Dien Bien Phu. Yep. They had withdrawn and the Americans had then come in basically because they were worried of the domino effect. And perhaps before we just get into this incredible end game, because today's theme is the fall of Saigon, Americans being removed from the rooftop of the embassy in choppers, all that kind of stuff. But Dominic, we're not the rest of geography, but just a quick sketch of what exactly, where North Vietnam is and South Vietnam relative to Cambodia, because this is rather important, isn't it? Okay, crikey. Well, hello, everybody. Yes, so we're in Vietnam in the mid-1970s,
他们在奠边府战役中被击败了。没错。他们撤出了，随后美国人进驻了，基本上是因为他们担心多米尼克效应（译者注：多米尼克/多米诺骨牌效应）。也许在我们切入这个不可思议的结局之前——因为今天的主题是西贡的沦陷，美国人乘直升机从大使馆屋顶撤离，以及诸如此类的事情——但是多米尼克，我们可不是“地理其余部分”，不过能简单勾勒一下北越和南越相对于柬埔寨的精确位置吗，因为这相当重要，不是吗？好吧，天哪。好吧，大家好。是的，所以我们正处于20世纪70年代中期的越南，
but as Tom says, a little bit of context. So Vietnam, for those people who don't know, is on the eastern side of the Indo-Chinese peninsula, which juts out into the South China Sea and the Gulf of Thailand. So Vietnam kind of snakes along the eastern side. So you've got Hanoi in the north, and that was the capital of North Vietnam. And then the division about halfway down the country that had been divided in the mid 1950s after the French had left. And there had been effectively two states created, North Vietnam, which is communist, South Vietnam, which is sort of in inverted commas democratic, but actually run by a succession of military hunters. And that kind of curls around at the bottom. And it's as though Vietnam kind of cradles Cambodia, doesn't it, Tom?
但正如汤姆所说，需要一点背景。所以，对于那些不知道的人来说，越南位于印度支那半岛的东侧，该半岛向南中国海和泰国湾突出一块。因此越南就像沿着东侧蜿蜒伸展。你在北部有河内，那是北越的首都。然后大约在国家中部有一个分界线，这是在20世纪50年代初法国离开后被划分的。实际上诞生了两个国家，一个是北越，属于共产主义阵营；另一个是南越，在某种程度上可以说是引号里的“民主”国家，但实际上由一连串军事独裁政权统治。底部则呈弯曲状。汤姆，这看起来就像越南环抱着柬埔寨一样，对吧？
So the Vietnamese and the Cambodians, although to sort of ignorant Western outsiders, they're basically the same. Of course, they're not if you're Vietnamese or Cambodian. There's an awful lot of tension, ethnic and historic tension between the two, which we'll perhaps come to later on. So what had happened is that the war had never really ended in Vietnam. The North and the South were meant to have been unified, but thanks largely to American pressure, they hadn't been in the 1950s.
因此，越南人和柬埔寨人，尽管在某些无知的西方局外人看来，他们基本上是一回事，但如果你是越南人或柬埔寨人，你当然知道根本不是这回事。两者之间存在着大量的紧张关系，包括种族和历史上的紧张关系，我们也许稍后会谈到这一点。所以发生的情况是，越南的战争从未真正结束。南北双方本来应该统一的，但在很大程度上由于美国的施压，他们在50年代并没有实现统一。
The Americans had poured in loads of aid to the South, and then, of course, loads of troops from the mid-1960s onwards. They'd spent $140 billion. They had sent in half a million men to try and prop up the Southern non-communist regime based in saigon uh 58 000 americans had been killed in this incredibly horrific i mean really savage war we did a podcast didn't we with andrew preston yeah tom uh in the early days of the rest is history in which he was talking about the sheer quantity of ordnance of bombs dropped on north vietnam being greater far greater than anything dropped in the Second
美国人向南方倾注了大量的援助，然后，从20世纪60年代中期开始，当然还派出了大量的军队。他们花费了1400亿美元。他们派出了50万士兵，试图支撑以西贡为基地的南部反共政权；呃，在这场令人难以置信的可怕——可以说是非常残酷的——战争中，有58000名美国人丧生。我们做过一期播客，对吧，邀请了安德鲁·普雷斯顿（Andrew Preston），是的，汤姆，在《历史其余部分》的早期节目中，他谈到投掷在北越的军火和炸弹的数量之纯粹庞大，远远超过了在第二次
World War. Just absolutely sort of devastated landscapes. And that had spilled over to Cambodia at the turn of the 1970s. Maybe we'll come back to that a little bit later in the podcast. But the North Vietnamese, first of all, had established what they call their sanctuaries in the jungle on the Cambodian side of the border. And Richard Nixon, in frustration, had finally decided to strike at them, first by secretly bombing them, and then by authorizing a full-scale invasion of eastern Cambodia. So that had been immensely controversial, and it had an extraordinarily destabilizing
世界大战中投掷的任何东西。简直可以说是满目疮痍的景观。而在20世纪70年代初，战火蔓延到了柬埔寨。也许我们在播客稍后会再回到这一点。但北越人首先在柬埔寨边界一侧的丛林中建立了他们所谓的庇护所。理查德·尼克松出于沮丧，终于决定对他们进行打击，起初是秘密轰炸，随后授权对柬埔寨东部进行全面入侵。这引起了巨大的争议，并对柬埔寨社会产生了
effect on Cambodian society. So when Fenton goes, as you say, as a young poet, he's won this prize, and he wants to go off to see what's going on in Saigon. I mean, technically you have, I'm going to use very large inverted commas, you have peace at this point because Henry Kissinger and Le Duc Tho, who was the North Vietnamese negotiator, had signed a peace agreement in January 1973 in Paris. And actually you've probably seen some of the listeners to this podcast would have seen some of the anniversary pieces. That was 50 years ago,
极其不稳定的破坏性影响。因此，正如你所说，当芬顿作为一名年轻诗人前去时，他赢得了这个奖项，他想去看看西贡正在发生什么。我的意思是，从技术上讲，我要用非常大的引号，此时你们是有和平的，因为亨利·基辛格和北越谈判代表黎德寿（Le Duc Tho）于1973年1月在巴黎签署了一项和平协议。事实上，收听这个播客的一些听众可能已经看过一些周年纪念文章了。那是50年前的事了，
in the beginning of this year, so-called peace in Vietnam. Peace with honor. Peace with honor, as Nixon called it, exactly. But as we'll discover, the Paris Peace Accords were nothing of the kind. And Nixon had basically signed that accord, committed still to upholding the independence of South Vietnam, and feeling that he would be able to because he was the president, and so he could do what he liked. But what snarls that up is that his presidency starts to unravel because of the Watergate scandal.
在今年年初，所谓的越南和平。带着尊严的和平。正如尼克松所说，带着尊严的和平，完全正确。但正如我们将发现的那样，巴黎和平协定根本不是那么回事。尼克松基本上签署了该协议，依然承诺维护南越的独立，并觉得他能够做到这一点，因为他是总统，所以他可以随心所欲。但将事情搞砸的是，他的总统任期开始因为水门事件丑闻而瓦解。
Well, so this is a hugely controversial topic. So they signed the accord in January 1973 after an awful lot of sort of back and forth. And in fact, Nixon and Kissinger had agreed what was called the Christmas bombing in an attempt to basically bomb the North Vietnamese into signing the deal. And in all that period, the Americans had been slowly drawing down their troop commitments and kind of switching to a policy of Vietnamization, which meant basically building up the South Vietnamese army. So getting them to do all the fighting for them. So they finally pull out the last troops, I think in March, 1973. So almost all the sort of ground troops are gone. There are still thousands of American advisors and CIA people and stuff left behind. But what do they think is going to happen? I mean, that's the question,
好吧，所以这是一个极具争议的话题。因此，经过了大量的前后拉锯后，他们在1973年1月签署了协议。事实上，尼克松和基辛格曾同意所谓的圣诞轰炸，试图以此从根本上轰炸北越，逼迫他们签署协议。在整个这段时期里，美国人一直在缓慢削减他们的兵力承诺，并转向一种越南化政策，这意味着基本上要建立南越军队。从而让他们代为承担所有的战斗。因此，我想他们在1973年3月最后撤出了最后一批军队。所以几乎所有的地面部队都走了。仍然有数千名美国顾问和中情局人员等留了下来。但他们认为会发生什么呢？我的意思是，这才是真正的问题所在。
really. So some people think that Nixon and Kissinger had always been disingenuous, that they knew that South Vietnam was going to fall. So in 1971, Kissinger had said to Chuen Lai, the Chinese, what he wanted was a sufficient interval between our withdrawal and what happens afterwards. So in other words, they thought that it might last 18 months, the Saigon regime, which in fact it did, or thereabouts, and that the Americans wouldn't then get the blame. So there's some people who think basically they were selling out South Vietnam. So it was cynical right from the outgo.
因此，有些人认为尼克松和基辛格一直都在虚伪行事，他们知道南越注定要沦陷。所以在1971年，基辛格曾对中国周恩来表示，他想要的是在我们撤军和随后的事情发生之间有一个“足够的间隔期”。换句话说，他们认为西贡政权可能会维持18个月，事实也确实如此，或者差不多这个时间，然后美国就不会因此承担责任。所以有些人认为他们基本上是在出卖南越。因此从一开始这就是冷血算计的。
Cynical right from the start because the fighting never ever stopped. Within days of the so-called ceasefire, there would be massive violations. The fighting just continued. And they had agreed that Viet Cong troops, so they're the sort of communist guerrillas who are in South Vietnam, that they could stay in South Vietnam. They wouldn't be withdrawn to the North or anything like that. So basically, the fighting is just carried on as though all that's happened is the Americans have gone home. So that's one argument that they're basically selling out South Vietnam. The other argument is that Nixon was being truthful when he said to South Vietnam's
从一开始就是冷血算计，因为战斗从未真正停止过。在所谓的停火几天之内，就会发生大规模的违约。战斗仍在继续。他们已经同意越共军队，也就是那些身处南越的共产主义游击队，可以留在南越。他们不会被撤回北方或类似的地方。因此基本上，战斗就像美国人只是回家了一样继续进行。所以这是一种观点，即他们基本上在出卖南越.另一种观点是，尼克松在对南越总统阮文秀（Nguyen Van Thieu）说话时是真诚的，尼克松曾对他说过、写信对他说过，
president, who's called Nguyen Van Thieu, Nixon had said to him, had written to him and said, you have my absolute assurance that if Hanoi fails to abide by the terms of this agreement, it is my intention to take severe and swift retaliatory action. Because Nixon's prestige as president is tied up with that, right? Right. Well, it's not just... So there are two different ways to look at it. One is to say, the Americans said they wanted peace, they should have gone home, end of story. The other way of looking at it, which is what President Tu of South Vietnam would say is, you've spent all this money and all this blood, not just of your own troops, but of our young men and our people in promising that you would uphold us as an independent nation.
你有我的绝对保证，如果河内未能遵守本协议的条款，我打算采取严厉而迅猛的报复行动。因为尼克松作为总统的声望与此息息相关，对吧？没错。好吧，这不仅仅是……所以有两种不同的看法。一种说法是，美国人说他们想要和平，他们本该回家，故事结束。另一种看法，也就是南越总统阮文秀会持有的观点是，你们花费了这么多的金钱和鲜血，不仅是你们自己的军队，还有我们年轻人和我们人民的鲜血，承诺你们将把我们作为一个独立国家支撑下去。
It would be utterly dishonorable for you to now run away and to leave us to face our fate. And Nixon has said to him on multiple occasions, I will not do that. And of course, you're right, Tom, that there is a cynical side to this, which is that Nixon, somebody who is obsessed with his own place in history and America's place in the world, that he does not want South Vietnam to fall on his watch. So there are a lot of historians who say, listen, when they signed that deal in January 1973, there was nothing peaceful about it because they knew, both sides knew that the fighting would go on straight away. And the American plan was always that they would immediately, as soon as the North Vietnamese sort of transgressed, they would just start bombing them again.
如果你们现在逃跑，留下我们去面对自己的命运，那是极其不光彩的。而尼克松曾多次对他说过，我不会那样做。当然，汤姆，你说得对，这里面确实有冷血算计的一面，那就是尼克松——一个痴迷于自己在历史上的地位以及美国在世界上的地位的人——他不希望南越在他的任内沦陷。因此，有很多历史学家说，听着，当他们在1973年1月签署那项协议时，里面没有任何和平可言，因为双方都知道，战斗会立刻继续下去。美国的计划始终是，一旦北越方面违规，他们就会立即重新开始轰炸。
So actually, this was pure smokescreen. But Nixon falls because of Watergate. And one of the consequences of Watergate, am I right, is that Congress introduces kind of increasing measures that are designed to chain the imperial presidency. Exactly. To stop presidents from kind of conducting foreign policy in the way that Kennedy and Johnson and Nixon had been doing. Exactly right. Yeah, exactly right. So in some ways, this podcast, today's podcast,
所以实际上，这纯粹是烟雾弹。但尼克松因为水门事件而下台。水门事件的后果之一，我没说错吧，就是国会出台了越来越多的旨在约束帝国总统制的措施。正是如此。阻止总统们像肯尼迪、约翰逊和尼克松那样推行外交政策。完全正确。是的，完全正确。所以在某种程度上，这个播客，今天的播客，
and the next podcast, they're kind of the sequel, not just to the Vietnam vietnam podcast but to the watergate podcast because those two things are so closely a prequel to the episodes we did on reagan exactly exactly tom so nixon falls in august 1974 by that point congress has already moved against him because he's weakened because of watergate and they have passed a thing called the case church amendments that prohibits any american military intervention in vietnam unless congress explicitly approves it. And even more controversial, at the end of 1973, the War Powers Resolution that limits presidential powers intervene anywhere at all without notifying Congress. So Nixon and Kissinger in their memoirs both say, we didn't let South Vietnam down. It was the Democrats, the Democrats in Congress,
以及接下来的播客，它们有点像是续集，不仅是越南战争播客的续集，也是水门事件播客的续集，因为这两件事与我们之前做的关于里根的剧集密切相关，可以说是前传。完全正确，完全正确，汤姆。所以尼克松于1974年8月下台。到那个时候，国会已经对他采取了行动，因为他在水门事件后已经失势，他们通过了一项名为“凯斯-丘奇修正案”（Case-Church Amendment）的法案，禁止任何美国在越南的军事干预，除非国会明确批准。更具争议的是，在1973年底，通过了《战争权力决议》（War Powers Resolution），限制了总统在不通知国会的情况下在任何地方进行干预的权力。因此尼克松和基辛格在各自的回忆录中都说，我们没有让南越失望。是民主党人，国会里的民主党人，
who wouldn't give us what we wanted. I mean, the implication of that is that they were secretly always planning to re-escalate the war once again, which was not what they were saying at the time. Or I suppose to set it up so that they wouldn't get the blame and they could blame Congress. Well, there you go. We don't really know. I think what they were doing was a sort of multiple track thing. I think deep down, doing was a sort of multiple track thing. I think deep down, Nixon and Kissinger always thought that they would have to restart the aerial war within months of the so-called peace in January 1973, because they knew that South Vietnam would struggle.
不肯给我们想要的东西。我的意思是，这其中的暗指是，他们暗地里一直计划再次升级战争，这与他们当时所说的话并不相符。或者我猜他们是在做铺垫，这样他们就不会受到指责，而是可以把责任推给国会。好吧，就是这样。我们其实并不知道。我认为他们当时在搞一种多管齐下的策略。我认为在内心深处，尼克松和基辛格一直认为，在所谓1973年1月和平之后的几个月内，他们将不得不重新开始空中战争，因为他们知道南越会举步维艰。
It's slightly smaller in population in North Vietnam, probably about 24 million to 20 million. But the South Vietnamese military and the whole of South Vietnam society had become so dependent on the massive American presence. Yes, because the American presence is basically fueling their economy. And so when all the Americans withdraw, that's not helpful for the economy. I mean, quite aside from the military angle of it. Exactly. That scene that James Fenton describes, he talks about Saigon as an addicted city, and we were the drug. And what I was first seeing was the first symptom of withdrawal.
南越的人口略少于北越，大约2400万对2000万。但南越军队和整个南越社会已经变得极其依赖庞大的美军存在。是的，因为美军的存在基本上在支撑着他们的经济。因此，当所有美国人撤走时，这对经济毫无帮助。我的意思是，这还不算军事角度。完全正确。詹姆斯·芬顿描述的那个场景，他将西贡形容为一个上瘾的城市，而我们就是毒品。我当时看到的第一个现象就是戒断症状的初期。
Yeah, cold turkey. I mean, it's literally an addicted city because one of the consequences of the American military occupation has been a massive heroin epidemic. There are estimates that there are up to half a million women who are involved in prostitution in some way. That there's a whole economy, by the way, an incredibly corrupt economy. There's a whole economy that has grown up to service the needs of this gigantic American military presence.
是的，戒毒断瘾。我的意思是，它字面意思上就是一个上瘾的城市，因为美军军事占领的后果之一就是爆发了大规模的海洛因流行病。据估计，有多达50万名女性以某种方式从事卖淫活动。顺便说一句，那里有着一整套经济，一个极其腐败的经济。已经成长起了一整套经济，专门用来满足这个庞大美军存在的各种需求。
And when that is withdrawn, South Vietnam's economy has been completely distorted. Plus in the countryside, the sort of rural economy has been destroyed by decades of fighting, by the bombing, by Agent Orange, the chemical weapons, and so on. So in other words, this is a country that has been dependent on American support, which has suddenly been withdrawn. And it's tottering right from that point onwards. And so the Viet Cong in the North know this, and they presumably are also aware of what's happening in America. So Nixon has gone, Gerald Ford, golfer, football player. Excellent football player, Tom. Excellent athlete, Gerald Ford. President most likely to fall over while on the camera.
而当这些被撤走时，南越的经济已经被彻底扭曲了。再加上在农村地区，乡村经济由于数十年的战斗、轰炸、橙剂（化学武器）等摧毁殆尽。换句话说，这是一个一直依赖美国支持的国家，而支持突然被撤走了。从那一刻起，它就一直在摇摇欲坠。因此北越的越共深知这一点，他们大概也意识到了美国正在发生的事情。所以尼克松走了，杰拉尔德·福特（Gerald Ford）上台了，高尔夫球手，足球运动员。出色的足球运动员，汤姆。杰拉尔德·福特是一位出色的运动员。最有可能在镜头前摔倒的总统。
The only president to have appeared in a Pink Panther film. He wasn't playing himself, somebody else was playing him in the Pink Panther strikes again. Well, so all these greatly to his credit but um his hands slightly tied in a way that that nixon's hands hadn't been so presumably in north vietnam they're aware of this and they start to launch strikes not with the aim of conquering south vietnam immediately but partly to test south vietnamese readiness but also what will the americans do yes how far can they push things before the Americans intervene? And presumably they are assuming the Americans will intervene or have they read the runes correctly in Washington? It's interesting. So in Cambodia,
唯一一位在《粉红豹》电影中出现过的总统。他演的不是他自己，在《粉红豹再次出击》（The Pink Panther Strikes Again）中别人演了他。好吧，所有这些都很值得称赞，但呃，他的手在某种程度上被束缚了，而尼克松的手则没有，所以北越人大概意识到了这一点，他们开始发动进攻，目的不是为了立即征服南越，部分是为了考验南越的战备状态，但也是为了看看美国人会怎么做。是的，在美军介入之前，他们能把事情推到多远？他们大概是在假设美国人会介入，还是说他们已经准确解读了华盛顿的密码？这很有趣。所以在柬埔寨，
the communists, the Khmer Rouge, they're more allied to China. The North Vietnamese are very close to Moscow, to the Brezhnev regime. And they're almost certainly getting intelligence from Moscow. They're just sort of saying, listen, the Americans are kind of gone now. You can start pushing. I think, as far as we know, the North Vietnamese had their eyes on about 1976 or so. And so from about the late summer of 1974, the North Vietnamese sort of big cheese. He's a guy called Lee Xuan.
共产主义者红色高棉（Khmer Rouge）更多地与中国结盟。北越与莫斯科、勃列日涅夫政权非常亲密。他们几乎肯定在从莫斯科获得情报。他们基本上是在说，听着，美国人现在基本上已经走了。你们可以开始施压了。我认为，据我们所知，北越人将目光锁定在1976年左右。因此，从1974年夏末开始，北越的头号人物——一个叫黎笋（Le Xuan）的人——
And he's actually from South Vietnam. So how does Ho Chi Minh fit in? He's been dead, Tom, for about six years. Okay. All right. So he died in 1969. I think it was... Sorry, I wasn't up to speed on that. That's all right.
他其实来自南越。那么胡志明是怎么回事？他已经去世了，汤姆，大约六年了。好吧。好的。所以他在1969年去世了……抱歉，我对这个不太了解。没关系。
So I should explain to listeners that what I have in front of me, because I know almost nothing about this subject, until I read the bootleg Sandbrook chapters from a book that you wrote about American history in this period. What was it? Half a million words and your publisher required it to be about 100,000. So you have to cut, bath, sway. So there are these two brilliant chapters that you had to reduce to one sentence. That's pretty much it. Yeah. That's pretty accurate. They're really fantastic so if there's any publisher out there listening who would who would like to have them and they're really really great commission am i paying you my agent will be furious at this so i read here that
所以我应该向听众解释，我面前放着的东西，因为我对这个主题几乎一无所得，直到我阅读了你写的一本关于这一时期美国历史的书中的盗版桑德布鲁克（Sandbrook）章节。是什么来着？五十万字，而你的出版商要求大约十万字。所以你不得不大刀阔斧地删减。所以有两个精彩的章节，你不得不浓缩成一句话。差不多就是这样。是的。这很准确。它们真的很棒，所以如果有任何出版商在收听，想要拥有它们，它们真的很棒——这是在向我约稿吗？我会付你钱吗？我的经纪人对此会气疯的。所以我在这里读到，
on the 6th january 1975 the communist flag was hoisted over the first provincial capital to fall for almost three years which was a place called fuck bin oh god that's the one bit you choose to read out that's very uh that's very restless history isn't it um uh yes you're absolutely right tom so fuck bin falls and that's clearly not good no that's not good at all bin has fallen all right stop tom stop the gates of of north south vietnam are open So what happens next? North South Vietnam. Right. So the communists had launched, I'm going to try and steer this podcast back into more reputable territory.
在1975年1月6日，共产主义旗帜在近三年来首个沦陷的省会城市上空升起，那是一个叫福隆（Phuc Bin）的地方——哦，天哪，那是你选择读出来的唯一一部分，这非常具有《历史其余部分》的风格，不是吗？——呃，是的，你绝对说得对，汤姆，所以福隆沦陷了，这显然不是什么好事。不，这绝对不是什么好事。福隆已经沦陷了。好了，停下，汤姆，停下。南北越南的大门敞开了。接下来会发生什么？南北越南。好吧。所以共产党人发起了一场——我要试着把这个播客引导回更体面的领域。
So the North Vietnamese had launched a big offensive in the summer of 1974. They hadn't really got much American pushback, of course, because Nixon is completely absorbed by Watergate at this point. So as you say, in January 1975, we don't need to go through the names of the towns again, Tom. They take a northern provincial capital and the leadership in Hanoi says, okay, start pushing. But they're thinking about laying the groundwork for a big
所以北越在1974年夏天发动了一场大攻势。他们当然没有真正遭到太多来自美国的阻击，因为此时尼克松完全沉浸在水门事件中。正如你所说，在1975年1月，我们不需要再念一遍那些城镇的名字了，汤姆。他们攻占了一个北部的省会城市，河内的领导层说，好吧，开始施压。但他们当时考虑的是为1976年发动一场新的大攻势奠定基础。当时并没有人感觉到阮文秀总统的政权已经到了崩溃的边缘。所以杰拉尔德·福特在华盛顿。他在打高尔夫球。他戴着一个写着“抑制通胀现在”（Whip Inflation Now）的徽章，这是他戴上的，他还鼓励其他美国人购买，以便公开展示他们对降低通胀的承诺。而且这非常容易戴上，不是吗？因为他西装的翻领非常宽。确实如此。他穿着，杰拉尔德·福特实际上穿着非常棒的西装。而且他穿着这种非常花哨的花呢西装之类的东西。
new offensive in 1976. And there's no sense at that point that President Chu's regime is on the brink. So Gerald Ford is in Washington. He's playing his golf. He's wearing a badge that says Whip Inflation Now, which he put on and he encouraged other Americans to buy so that they would publicly display their commitment to getting inflation down. And it's very easy to fit on, isn't it? Because the lapels of his suit are enormously wide. They are. He's wearing, he wears tremendous suits, Gerald Ford, actually. And he wears this sort of very garish kind of tweed suits and things.
他抽烟斗。他和詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）是好朋友。所以杰拉尔德·福特有很多值得称赞的地方。我向听众推荐他。不管怎样，他在做他自己的事。阮总统不断地说，你知道的，给我更多的援助，派遣支持，诸如此类的事情。然后到了1975年，北越没有发动另一场大推进，他们开始向下推进——所以我把南北越描述为一条沿着印度支那半岛东侧向下的蛇——他们正在向南移动，呃，到了1975年3月左右，他们正在进入所谓的中央高地。所以这是南越中部的一处高原。正是在那个时候，西贡（南越首都）的阮文秀总统犯下了一个灾难性的错误。他说，我们要做的基本上是将共产党人引入陷阱。所以我们将从我们国家的北部撤走大量军队，并向南靠近西贡的方向加强防守，把他们引下来，然后我们再出击。而他没有真正考虑到的是，在军事上，没有什么比后撤更困难的了。那是你最脆弱的时刻。而且组织一场有战斗力的撤退真的非常非常难。而基本上发生的情况是，到1975年3月下旬，南越军队正在后撤，并且非常非常迅速地变成了一场完全混乱且如噩梦般的溃败。因此他们失守了一个至关重要的城市，叫作波来古（Pleiku），
He smokes a pipe. He's great friends with James Callaghan. So there's lots to commend Gerald Ford. I commend him to the listeners. Anyway, he's doing his thing. President Chu is constantly saying, you know, give me more aid, send support, all this sort of stuff. And then in of 1975 the north vietnamese not another great push and they're sort of pushing down so i described north and south vietnam as like a snake going down the
位于中央高地。所以这些名字对于在新闻中夜复一夜看到它们的美国人来说会非常熟悉。他们自己的军队在战斗……突然间这有点像1918年第一次世界大战的结束，本质上是一个稳定的战线，然后全面崩溃。是的，一旦你开始后撤，突然间——我的意思是人们总是这样评价军队——军队溃败，非常、非常缓慢，然后突然就崩溃了。这就是发生的事情。所以他们失守了波来古。
eastern side of the indo-chinese peninsula they're kind of moving southwards and um by about march 1975 they're moving into what's called the central Highlands. So that's this kind of plateau in the middle of South Vietnam. And it's at that point that President Thieu in Saigon, the South Vietnamese capital, makes this catastrophic mistake. And he says, what we're going to do is we're basically going to lure the communists into a trap. So we'll withdraw a lot of our troops from the northern bit of our country, and we'll strengthen down to the
他们失守了沿海一个叫顺化（Hue）的地方，那是越南的古都。因此到3月底，突然之间，南越将近四分之一的领土已经失守。有数百万——我的意思是，字面意思上超过一百万的惊恐难民堵塞了道路，这当然使他们更难组织任何形式的军事反应。因此，中情局情报站长拍电报给华盛顿，说这是一场灾难，除非我们有美军介入，否则一切都会彻底崩盘。所以这对福特和国会来说都是一个巨大的问题，对吧？是的。所以在那时，福特已经——福特没有当选。我的意思是，这至关重要。
south near Saigon, and we'll lure them down, and then we will strike. And what he doesn't really take into account is that militarily, there is nothing more difficult than going backwards. That's the point at which you're most vulnerable. And it's really, really hard to kind of organize a fighting retreat. And what basically happens is that by late March 1975, the South Vietnamese army is going backwards, and it turns very, very quickly into a kind of completely shambolic and a nightmarish rout. So they lose a crucial sort of city, which is called Pleiku,
福特没有经过选举上台，但他想在1976年竞选连任。所以他有这种恐惧，他面临一系列可怕的困境，其中之一就是他是否要赦免尼克松？他确实赦免了。但另一个困境是，他该如何处理越南？因为事实是，到现在为止，美国大多数人都希望越南问题消失。那些想要继续在越南打仗的人，基本上是那些从一开始就参与战争、在维护尊严方面有某种个人利益的人。
which is in the central highlands. So these are names that would have been very familiar to people in america who had seen them night after night on the news their own troops fight suddenly it's a bit like um the end of the first world war in 1918 essentially a kind of stable front and then it's all collapsing yeah that once you once you start going backwards suddenly i mean people always say it about armies armies collapse very collapse very, very slowly and then suddenly. And this is what happens. So they lose Pleiku.
这就像是一种沉没成本谬误。我猜他们会辩称这是为了美国的尊严。美国的尊严，但他们也认为这是正确的事情。是的。他们认为我们曾有一个非共产主义国家，它正受到共产主义国家的攻击。尽管他们知道南越是独裁的，但这依然是正确的事情。是的。他们认为我们曾有一个非共产主义国家，它正受到共产主义国家的攻击。尽管他们知道南越是独裁的、腐败的、充满种种弊端，
They lose a place called Hue on the coast, which is the ancient capital of Vietnam. And so by the end of March, quite suddenly, almost a quarter of South Vietnam's territory has been lost. And there are millions, I mean, there's literally more than a million terrified refugees blocking the roads, of course, which makes it even more difficult for them to organise any kind of military response. And so the CIA station chief wires Washington and says, this is a disaster, it's all going to go into meltdown unless we have US involvement. And so that is a massive problem for both Ford and Congress, right? Right. So at that point, so Ford has been in, Ford's not been elected. I mean, this is crucial.
他们依然认为它值得捍卫。尼克松走了，但基辛格还在。他是国务卿。是的。基辛格对福特有着巨大的影响。所以亨利·基辛格，对于那些不了解亨利·基辛格的人来说，亨利·基辛格是20世纪70年代一个巨大无比的国际人物。他现在是国务卿。他是一位来自德国的犹太难民，对美国及其在世界上的角色有着深厚的信仰。他致力于冷战，
Ford has not been elected, but he wants to run again in 1976. So he has this sort of terror, he's got a series of terrible dilemmas, one of which was, was he going to pardon Nixon? And he did. But another one is, what does he do about Vietnam? Because the truth is that by now, most people in America want Vietnam to go away. The people who want to carry on with the war in Vietnam are basically those people who've been instrumental in the war from the beginning, who've got a kind of personal stake in wanting to uphold their honor.
致力于势力范围的平衡、美国的尊严、美国的威望。他知道南越陷入了困境，但他不希望它以彻底损害美国尊严等方式分崩离析。再次阅读你的盗版章节。是的。在3月27日，他对福特说，我怀着滴血的心情说这话，但也许你必须把越南抛在脑后，不要再次把国家撕裂。
It's like a kind of sunk cost fallacy. And I guess they would argue America's honor. America's honor, but also they think it's the right thing to do. Yeah. They think we had a non-communist country and it's under attack from a communist country. Even though they know that South Vietnam is repressive, it's the right thing to do. Yeah. They think we had a non-communist country and it's under attack from a communist country. Even though they know that South Vietnam is repressive, it's corrupt, all these things,
是的。所以基辛格，基辛格的问题在于他非常矛盾。所以他在不同的时间点会说，你知道的，哦，南越已经完了。这一切都是一场可怕的灾难。然后第二天，他又会说，不过，如果我们能为南越提供数百万的援助，为柬埔寨提供超过2亿美元的援助，那就太好了。国会说不，绝对不行。阮总统一直在写信给他，求求你，你能授权轰炸正在推进的北方部队吗？求求你，你能帮帮我们吗？但他不能，对吧，如果没有国会的批准？没有国会的批准。所以他不能。他所做的是，福特有点举棋不定。在3月底，他决定他要做的，
they still think it's worth defending. And Nixon is gone, but Kissinger is still around. He's Secretary of State. Yeah. Kissinger is a huge influence on Ford. So Henry Kissinger, for those people who don't know Henry Kissinger, Henry Kissinger is a massive, massive international figure in the 1970s. He's now the Secretary of State. He is a former Jewish refugee from Germany who sort of has a deep belief in America and its role in the world. He's committed to the Cold War,
就是派遣越南的最后一位美军指挥官，一个叫弗雷德里克·韦安德（Frederick Weyand）将军的人。他要派他去实地考察一下，看看这是否值得任何未来的投资。韦安德去了印度支那，并在1975年4月5日返回，他基本上说南越正处于全面军事失败的边缘。然而他接着又说，另一方面，如果你能给他们7亿美元，并授权B-52轰炸机打击共产主义阵营的阵地，那么它也许就能存活下来。然后在说了这一切之后，有一段非常“亨利·基辛格”风格的话，他说，我们必须这样做，因为现在越南关乎的是美国的信誉。
committed to the balance of power, American honor, American prestige. And he knows that South Vietnam is in trouble, but he doesn't want it to fall apart in such a way that it completely compromises American honor and so on. Again, reading from your bootleg chapter. Yeah. On the 27th of March, he tells Ford, I say this with a bleeding heart, but maybe you must put Vietnam behind you and not tear the country apart again.
它是一个盟友。我们绝不能放弃我们对一个自由独立越南的目标。这就唤起了基本上要重启战争的幽灵。奇怪的是，随着他的离开，福特身边有一个类似弄臣的角色，就像白宫里的一个小丑。所以他有一个叫大卫·肯尼利（David Kennerly）的人——我对大卫·肯尼利有点严苛了，他其实是个非常优秀的摄影师。他是《时代》杂志的摄影师，福特基本上让他留在白宫担任自己的私人摄影师。肯尼利在福特政府中非常不寻常，因为
Yeah. So Kissinger, the trouble with Kissinger is he's very contradictory. So he'll say at various points, you know, oh, South Vietnam is lost. It's all a terrible disaster. And then the next day, he'll sort of say, however, it'd be great if we million for aid for South Vietnam, more than $200 million for Cambodia. And Congress said no, under no circumstances. President Chu is writing to him all the time saying, please, will you authorize bombing strikes against the advancing northern forces? Please, will you help us? But he can't, can he, without Congress's permission? Without Congress's permission. So he can't. What he does is, Ford is sort of dithering a bit. And at the end of March, he decides that what he's
他留着胡子，穿着牛仔裤到处走，他告诉福特实际发生了什么，而不是福特想听到的。是的，所以他就像个小丑。他告诉福特实际发生了什么，而不是福特想听到的。是的，所以他就像个小丑。他就像李尔王的弄臣，完全是的。他曾去过越南，并和韦安德将军一起执行了这次任务。他回来后拿出了所有这些照片——事实上福特最后把它们贴在了白宫的墙上——肯尼利说，这才是真正发生的事情。这简直是纯粹的、纯粹的、纯粹的混乱。无论将军们对你说什么，他说，引述：“如果他们说越南还能撑三四周，那他们就是在胡扯（bullshitting you）。”毫无疑问。它撑不下去了。所以福特最后做了一次尝试。他去找
going to do, he's going to send the last US Army commander in Vietnam, who's a guy called General Frederick Wyand. He's going to send him to go and have a look and see if this is worth any future investment. And Wyand goes off to Indochina and he gets back on the 5th of april 1975 and he basically says south vietnam is on the brink of a total military defeat and yet he then says on the other hand if you could give them 700 million dollars and you could authorize b-52s to hit the communist positions then it might be able to survive and then having said all that he then there's a bit which is very sort of Henry Kissinger where he says, we have to do it because what's at stake at Vietnam now is America's credibility.
国会要钱。我想他这么做主要是为了给自己留退路。所以他说，请给我7亿美元用于援助越南。国会说，不，公众强烈反对。民调显示，十分之八的人认为他们应该让南越自生自灭。所以他照办了。大约在这个时候，南越真的、真的在嘎吱作响，也许我们应该在这集的上半部分结尾时，汤姆，讲讲在岘港（Da Nang）发生了什么。所以岘港在海岸线上。它是南越最大的城市之一。
It's an ally. We must not abandon our goal of a free and independent Vietnam. So that raises a specter of basically, let's restart the war. The weird thing is that with him has gone, Ford has this kind of jester, a sort of fool at the White House. so he's got this guy called david kennelly i'm being a bit harsh on david kennelly he's actually a very good photographer so he was a time magazine photographer who basically ford keeps on as his own personal photographer in the white house and kennelly is very unusual in the ford administration because
从3月下旬开始，它就遭到了共产主义军队的轰炸，大约就是韦安德将军前往越南的时候。随着共产党军队逼近岘港郊区，成千上万的人基本上向码头移动。他们挤进渔船、驳船和各种木船里——这绝对不是“泰坦尼克号”式的行为，对吧？
he has a beard and he goes around wearing jeans and he tells ford what's actually happening rather than right what ford wants to hear yeah so he is like a fool he tells ford what's actually happening rather than right what ford wants to hear yeah so he is like a fool he's like leah's fool exactly he is and he had been in vietnam before and he goes off to on this mission with general wyand and he comes back and he gets out all these photographs and actually ford ended up sticking them up on the walls of the white house the photographs and kelly says this is actually what's really going on. It is utter, utter, utter chaos. Whatever the generals tell you, he says, quote, they are bullshitting you if they say that Vietnam has got more than three or four weeks left. There's no question about it. It's not going to last. So Ford has one last go anyway. He goes to
这不是妇孺优先。基本上是妇女和儿童被踢在脸。所以你看到保罗·沃格尔（Paul Vogel），一位美国记者。我看到其中一个人踢了一个老妇人的脸才挤上船。所以，汤姆，这是一个惊人的故事。所以我们就在这里结束上半场。有一个叫埃德·戴利（Ed Daly）的人，他是某些美国听众可能听说过的一家名为“世界航空”（World Airways）的航空公司的创始人。这是一家很小的私人航空公司，属于廉价航空，埃德·戴利是一个非常了不起的慈善家。多年来，他一直允许自己的航空公司用飞机从加利福尼亚运送军事装备和援助物资到越南。他在报纸上读到了正在发生的事情。
Congress and he asks for money. He does that really to cover his own back, I think. So he says, please give me $700 million for the aid to Vietnam. And Congress says, no, the public are massively against it. So polls say that eight out of 10 people think they should just leave the South Vietnamese to their fate, as it were. And so he does. And then at about this point, South Vietnam is really, really creaking. And maybe we should end this half of the episode, Tom, with this, what happens in Da Nang. So Da Nang is on the coast. It's one of the biggest South Vietnamese cities.
他说，听着，我弄两架我的飞机去岘港，去救援这些被人踢了脸、扔进海里以及所有这些事情的人。我要亲自去监督。他去了，他们的飞机降落在岘港的停机坪上。飞机刚一降落，一群大约4000人的暴徒就包围了飞机，急于登机。埃德·戴利本人就站在舷梯底部。他字面意思上在大喊“妇孺优先”之类的话。但他被这群乌合之众撞倒了，其中大部分人其实是士兵，是南越士兵，他们在人群中朝着其他人盲目开枪。还把老妇人的脸踢得鼻青脸肿。
It's coming under communist bombardment from a very late March, so about the point when General Nguyen goes off to Vietnam. And people, as the communists approach the suburbs of Da Nang, people, tens of thousands of them, are basically moving towards the docks. They're packing into fishing boats and barges and any kind of wooden- And it's very much not Titanic behavior, is it?
所以最后，飞机上挤满了数千人，其中只有两个女人和一个孩子，其余的都是南越海军陆战队员。当飞机起飞时，那些没有挤上飞机的人开始向飞机开枪。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。有些人从飞机上掉下来，因为他们一直抓着——抓着起落架。起落架，是的。或者钻进了行李舱。所以至少有几个人，我想，在飞机起飞时掉进了海里。
It is not women and children first. It's basically women and children get kicked in the face. And so you've got Paul Vogel, an American reporter. I saw one of them kick an old woman in the face to get aboard. So Tom, this is an amazing story. So we'll just end this half for this. There's a guy called Ed Daly, who is a founder of an airline that some of our American listeners may have heard of called World Airways, which is this tiny kind of private airline, no frills airline. And Ed Daly was a great kind of philanthropist. And he had, for years, allowed his airline to fly military equipment from California and aid and stuff from California to Vietnam. And he reads in the newspapers about what's going on.
保罗·沃格尔是一位目睹这一幕的记者，他说，但留在脑海中的面孔是那个躺在停机坪上的老妇人的脸，她看着生命本身从指尖溜走，朝另一个方向滚去。好的，我们在那里休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将以更快的速度走向西贡的沦陷。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量秀场八卦的地方。
And he says, listen, I'll get two of my planes to go to Da Nang and to rescue these people who have been kicked in the face and thrown overboard and all this sort of stuff. And I'll go to supervise it personally. And he goes, and they land on the sort of tarmac in Da Nang. And as they land, a mob of kind of 4,000 people engulf the plane, desperate to board. And Ed Daly himself is standing at the bottom of this ramp. And he's literally saying kind of, women and children first. And he is knocked over by this huge mob, most of whom are actually soldiers, South Vietnamese soldiers, who are like firing randomly at their own other people in the crowd. And kicking old women in the face.
在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。我们正在关注西贡的沦陷。多米尼克，当我们离开时，你正在描述飞机起飞、海军陆战队员冲上飞机、人们掉入海中以及各种事情的混乱景象。而这种混乱大概不仅折磨着岘港的机场，还折磨着整座城市以及远处的乡村。是的，没错。所以我们以一个故事结束了——
So in the end, the plane is packed with thousands of people, among whom are just two women and one child, and the rest of them are South Vietnamese Marines. And as the plane takes off, the people who haven't got on the plane just start firing at the plane. I mean, it's absolutely crazy. And there are people who are dropping off who've been hanging on to the... Hanging on to the undercarriage. The undercarriage, yeah. Or got into the baggage hold. So there are at least a couple of people, I think, fell into the sea as the plane kind of takes off.
最终，飞机上挤满了数千人，其中只有两名妇女和一个儿童，其余都是南越海军陆战队员。当飞机起飞时，那些没有挤上飞机的人开始向飞机开枪。我的意思是，这简直太疯狂了。有些人从飞机上掉下来，他们之前一直抓着……抓着起落架。是啊，起落架。或者钻进了行李舱。所以至少有几个人，我想，在飞机起飞时掉进了海里。
And Paul Vogel, who is a journalist who is watching this, he says, but the face that remains is that of the old woman lying there on the tarmac, seeing life itself just off the end of her fingertips and rolling the other way. Okay, we'll take a break there. And when we come back, we will move that much faster towards the fall of Saigon. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
保罗·沃格尔是一位目睹这一幕的记者，他说，但留在脑海里的面孔是那个躺在停机坪上的老妇人的面孔，她看着生命本身从指尖溜走，向着另一个方向逝去。好的，我们先休息一下。回来后，我们将以更快的速度走向西贡的沦陷。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐秘史》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点八卦的必听节目。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are looking at the fall of Saigon. And Dominic, when we left, you were describing the chaos of planes taking off and marines storming on board and people dropping into the sea and all kinds of things. And presumably this chaos is not just afflicting the airport at Da Nang, but the whole city and countryside beyond. Yeah, that's right. So we ended with a story about
在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外节目以及提前获得现场门票的机会，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史秘史》。我们正在回顾西贡的沦陷。多米尼克，我们刚才离开时，你正在描述飞机起飞、海军陆战队员冲上飞机、人们掉入海里等各种混乱场景。想必这种混乱不仅困扰着岘港机场，还波及了整个城市及周边乡村。是的，没错。所以我们以一个故事结束了上一段
Ed Daly and his World Airways or whatever it's called. And there are many more stories like that. So there's an American evacuation ship called the Pioneer Contender where South Vietnamese troops are rescued and they run amok. They kill 24 25 of the other refugees they steal their money they rape people they take one guy's life savings off them they throw him into the sea and the american crew actually end up barricading themselves into their cabins because they're so terrified so it's all absolute heart of darkness stuff and you could see why a young poet would want to go and see all this i mean this is this is kind of iliad stuff the horrors of war and the crazy thing is that um the communists march into danang i think the next day so easter sunday 1975 and gerald ford you know what he's
埃d·戴利和他的世界航空公司，随便叫什么名字吧。类似的故事还有很多。当时有一艘美国撤离船叫“先锋竞争者号”，南越士兵在船上被救起，然后他们就彻底失控了。他们杀害了其他难民中的24、25人，偷走他们的钱，强奸妇女，抢走了一个人的全部积蓄，把他扔进海里，最后美国船员甚至把自己反锁在船舱里，因为他们吓坏了，这简直就是彻头彻尾的黑暗之心。你能理解为什么一个年轻的诗人会想去亲眼看看这一切，我的意思是，这有点像《伊利亚特》里那种战争的恐怖。而疯狂的是，呃，我记得共产主义武装第二天就开进了岘港，也就是1975年的复活节星期天，而杰拉尔德·福特，你知道他在
doing tom playing golf he is playing golf he's playing golf in palm springs and newspaper men come up to him and say uh what do you think about what's going on in Da Nang and he just sort of chuckles he says and he sort of chuckles off
干什么吗，汤姆？他在打高尔夫球。他在打高尔夫球。他在棕榈泉打高尔夫球。记者们走过去对他说：“呃，你对岘港正在发生的事情怎么看？”他只是笑笑，然后把这事
and he sort of why is he chuckling he's just embarrassed they've caught him when he's trying to play his golf relax yeah
他只是笑笑……他为什么在笑？他只是觉得尴尬，因为他打高尔夫球放松时被抓了个正着，是啊。
okay I think I think he's but he actually watches the footage of himself that evening which is juxtaposed
好吧，我想……我想他其实……但他当晚确实看了自己的新闻片段，这些画面与
with these apocalyptic kind of pictures from Vietnam and he says to a friend of his you know know, this is awful. You know, he knows how bad it looks. He says, Vietnam's gone. We just have to kind of get out.
来自越南的末日般的画面并置在一起，他对一个朋友说：“你知道，这太可怕了。”你知道的，他知道这看起来有多糟糕。他说：“越南已经完了。我们只能想办法撤离。”
But the tragedy, of course, and this will now be very, you know, it'll ring a lot of bells with anybody who was watching the pictures from Afghanistan when Afghanistan fell to the Taliban, when Kabul fell to the Taliban. You know, you can't get out that easily. It's really complicated and difficult. And you feel like you have obligations. And there are all kinds of tragedies. So just like there were tragedies at Kabul airport, just a couple of days later, there's one of the biggest tragedies. So yet another humanitarian gesture. This was called Operation Babylift. And this was a big transport plane that had been chartered to take Vietnamese orphans to the United States.
但悲剧在于，当然了——现在这会对任何看过阿富汗陷落于塔利班、喀布尔陷落于塔利班时那些画面的人产生极大的共鸣——你知道的，你想脱身可没那么容易。这非常复杂和艰难。你会觉得你负有责任。各种悲剧都会上演。就像喀布尔机场发生的悲剧一样，仅仅几天后，最大的一场悲剧之一就发生了。又是一次人道主义姿态，这被称为“婴儿lift行动”（Operation Babylift）。这是一架大型运输机，被租来把越南孤儿运往美国。
And they basically strapped three kids into each adult seat, so 243 children in all. And they take off and the plane basically, a door blows out and 135 people are killed. And even at the time, a lot of journalists say this is the most terrible metaphor. Like their daily flights. These are the most dreadful metaphors for American intervention in Vietnam. Good intentions, technology. But ends up with legs scattered over paddy fields. Exactly right. Exactly right. So there are a lot of journalists there. I mean, some of the American, there's a sort of Library of America two-volume edition of war reporting from Vietnam. And if anybody's never read about the Vietnam War and is interested in writing about it, the war reporting is better than any history book.
他们基本上把三个孩子塞进一个成年人的座位里，总共243名儿童。他们起飞了，然后飞机基本上……一个舱门被吹飞了，135人丧生。甚至在当时，许多记者就说这是一个最可怕的比喻。就像他们日常的航班一样。这是对美国干涉越南最糟糕的隐喻。良好的意愿，先进的技术。但最终的结果却是残肢断臂散落在稻田里。完全正确。完全正确。所以那里有很多记者。我的意思是，有些美国记者——有一本两卷本的越南战争战地报道文集，由美国文库出版。如果有人从没读过关于越南战争的书，但有兴趣了解或撰写这段历史，这些战地报道比任何历史书都要精彩。
Because the really, really brilliant writers would be sent by their papers. They'd have unfettered access because the American military was so useless as sort of censorship. So they would see everything. And you get these stories, I mean, there's a guy who was an ex-Marine called Philip Caputo, who later wrote a brilliant book about B&M. And he talks about the flow of people,
因为那些真正极其出色的作家会被各大报社派往前方。他们能获得不受限制的采访权限，因为美军在新闻审查方面实在太无能了。所以他们能看到一切。你会听到这些故事，我的意思是，有一个曾是海军陆战队员的家伙叫菲利普·卡普托（Philip Caputo），他后来写了一本关于越南的精彩著作。他谈到人群的流动，
what's he called it? A stream of flesh and blood and bone of exhausted, frightened faces of crushed hope and loss along the roads, flooding South all the time. This is the end of the road, his report ends, the end of a war. And the nearness of an end is all there is to mitigate the incalculable suffering of the Vietnamese who are making their last march down the street without joy. Yeah, brilliant stuff. But also, I can't remember where I read it, but it must have been in your book. The same with photography, that there are photographs
他是怎么称呼的？“一股血肉和白骨的洪流，充满了疲惫、惊恐的面孔，破碎的希望和失去的一切，沿路不断地向南涌去。这就是路的尽头，”他的报道以此结尾，“一场战争的尽头。”而末日的逼近，是唯一能减轻那些进行无望南下、没有欢乐的人们那不可估量的苦难的东西。是的，太精彩了。但还有，我不记得在哪里读到的了，但一定是在你的书中。摄影也是如此，有些照片
that are so hideous that they can never be shown. So am I right that there's a photograph of a head being taken out of a boiling pot of water or something? Yeah, there's loads of things like that. Hideous things like that. And the sense of an inferno, which then becomes incredibly enhanced by what is going on in Cambodia across the border, which is even by the scale of an inferno, which then becomes incredibly enhanced by what is going on in Cambodia across the border, which is even by the scale of the Vietnam War, you're into a fresh circle of hell there. Yeah. So this incredible thing that South Vietnam is collapsing, this Cold War effort into which
是如此骇人听闻，以至于永远无法公开。所以我是对的吗？有一张照片显示一颗人头从一锅沸水中捞出来，还是什么的？是的，有大量类似的事情。诸如此类骇人听闻的事情。那种身处炼狱的感觉，随后被柬埔寨边境那边正在发生的事情急剧放大。哪怕以地狱的规模来衡量，边境那边的局势——即使按照越南战争的规模来衡量，你也在那里踏入了新的一层地狱。是的。所以这种南越正在崩溃的惊人局面，这场冷战努力，美国人为此倾注了
the Americans had pumped so many billions of dollars and so many thousands of lives. And in the middle of all this, Cambodia is also collapsing. So Cambodia was a real tragedy because Cambodia had been basically a sort of peaceful kingdom. Under Prince Chinook, is that right? Yeah, Prince Chinook. And had basically been ripped apart first by both sides using it as a kind of battleground. Because, I mean, obviously, I know lots of people aren't looking at a map. But if you look at a map, as I said at the beginning, Vietnam kind of slightly cradles Cambodia, curls around it.
如此多的数十亿美元和数千条生命。而在这一切的中心，柬埔寨也正在崩溃。所以柬埔寨是一个真正的悲剧，因为柬埔寨基本上是一个和平的王国。在西哈努克亲王统治下，是这样吗？是的，西哈努克亲王。基本上被彻底撕裂了，首先是双方都把它当作某种战场来利用。因为，我的意思是，很显然，我知道很多人没有在看地图。但如果你看一下地图，就像我一开始说的，越南有点像把柬埔寨拥在怀里，环绕着它。
It's like a snake squeezing a baby. Exactly. And first, the North Vietnamese had established their bases in Cambodia. Then the Americans had bombed them and then invaded them. Law and order, society, the ecological system, the harvest, all those things, the rice harvests had completely broken down in Cambodia. That opened the way for an initially very small guerrilla group called the Khmer Rouge. They're largely illiterate young men, boys from the rural villages commanded by kind of fanatical university educated communists. But university educated communists who hate the university educated and particularly people with glasses. I wouldn't have fared well.
就像一条蛇在挤压一只幼崽。完全正确。首先，北越人在柬埔寨建立了他们的基地。然后美国人轰炸了他们，接着又入侵了柬埔寨。法律与秩序、社会、生态系统、收成、所有这些事情，柬埔寨的水稻收成彻底崩溃了。这为后来被称为“红色高棉”的、最初规模很小的游击队扫清了道路。他们主要是来自农村村庄的几乎不识字的年轻男子、男孩，由一些狂热的受过大学教育的共产主义者指挥。但这些受过大学教育的共产主义者却痛恨受过大学教育的人，尤其是戴眼镜的人。我可就惨了。
No, you have no time for the Khmer Rouge, do you, Tom? I'm not a fan. No. So while all this has been going on, the Khmer Rouge have been advancing on Phnom Penh, the capital of Cambodia. Now, Americans obviously don't have anything like the same investment in Cambodia, but they do have an embassy. So this is kind of like a dry run for what's going to follow in Saigon. Except in this case, the Americans do manage to pretty much get out. They said they've got the last flight. They get out 82 Americans and 152 Cambodians.
不，你可容不下红色高棉，对吧，汤姆？我不是他们的粉丝。不。所以当这一切发生的时候，红色高棉一直在向柬埔寨首都金边推进。现在，美国人对柬埔寨显然没有投入同样的精力，但他们确实有一个大使馆。所以这有点像接下来要在西贡发生的事情的预演。只不过在这种情况下，美国人确实设法差不多成功撤离了。他们说那是最后一趟航班。他们撤出了82名美国人和152名柬埔寨人。
They have the ambassador, who's a guy called John Gunter Dean. He's the last to go. He's folded up the American flag. And it's relatively decorous. But even then, there were the most awful tragedies. So John Gunter Dean, the ambassador, he got a letter just before he left from a guy called Prince Sirik Matak, who had actually been a prime minister of Cambodia. And he had said to this guy, come with us, the Khmer Rouge will kill you. And Sirik Matak wrote this letter, which actually does bear rereading because he says, I thank you very sincerely for your offer to transport me towards freedom. I cannot, alas, leave in such a cowardly fashion.
他们的大使是一个叫约翰·冈瑟·迪恩（John Gunter Dean）的人。他是最后一个离开的。他降下了美国国旗。整个过程相对体面。但即便如此，还是发生了最可怕的悲剧。所以大使约翰·冈瑟·迪恩在离开前不久收到了一封信，写信人是一个叫施里·玛塔克王子（Prince Sirik Matak）的人，他曾担任过柬埔寨首相。他曾对这个人说：“跟我们一起走吧，红色高棉会杀了你的。”而施里·玛塔克写了这封信，这封信确实值得重新阅读，因为他在信中写道：“我非常真诚地感谢你提出用飞机送我走向自由的提议。然而，恕我难以为继，我无法以如此懦弱的方式离开。”
As for you, and in particular for your great country, I never believed for a moment that you would have this sentiment of abandoning a people which has chosen liberty. You've refused us your protection and we can do nothing about it. You leave, and my wish is that you and your country will find happiness under the sky. But mark it well that if I shall die here on this spot and in my country that I love, it's no matter, because we're all born and we all must die i have only committed this mistake of believing in you imagine what a letter that is to receive and then the kamar rouge arrive and they shoot syracmatic in the stomach and uh he lies there for three days and dies yeah exactly so henry kissinger tells that story in his memoirs i mean henry kissinger
“至于你，尤其是为了你伟大的国家，我从未有一刻相信你们会做出抛弃一个选择自由的人民的举动。你们拒绝了我们的保护，对此我们无可奈何。你们离去了，我唯愿你和你的国家能在苍穹之下找到幸福。但请务必记住，如果我将死在这里，在这个我热爱的国家，这也无所谓，因为我们生来就要死去。我唯一犯下的错误，就是相信了你们。”想象一下，收到这样一封信是怎样的一种感受。然后红色高棉到了，他们朝施里·玛塔克的肚子开枪，呃，他在那里躺了三天然后死去了。嗯，确实如此。所以亨利·基辛格在他的回忆录中讲述了这个故事。我的意思是，亨利·基辛格
clearly blames Congress for that. But I mean, Henry Kissinger himself is not entirely blameless. I think it's very fair to say. And we might do another episode on the Khmer Rouge, but just very briefly, the sense of madness and cruelty generating this kind of hell is absolutely manifest in the first days of the Khmer Rouge takeover of Phnom Penh, that all the people who live in the city are forced to go out into the countryside. And actually, so the US ambassador, John Gunter Dean, he had predicted that. He had said the infrastructure will be everybody involved in the infrastructure of this country and everybody involved with all the Buddhist monks, all the civil servants, all
显然将此归咎于国会。但我的意思是，亨利·基辛格本人也并非完全没有责任。我认为这样说非常公允。我们可能会就红色高棉做另一期节目，但简而言之，红色高棉接管金边头几天所表现出的那种疯狂与残忍所酿成的地狱般景象，是绝对显而易见的。所有住在城里的人都被强行赶到乡下去。事实上，美国大使约翰·冈瑟·迪恩曾预测过这一点。他说过，基础设施将被摧毁——这个国家基础设施中的所有人，所有与佛教僧侣有关的人，所有的公务员，所有
of these people, he said, they will be killed because we know what the Khmer Rouge have done to the villages they've occupied. And the amazing thing is that most of the press corps at the time said- This is going to be all right. Because they can't comprehend it. Right. This is Cold War alarmism. So the most famous example of that is actually one of the guys who's often seen as one of
这些人，他说，他们都会被杀害，因为我们知道红色高棉对他们占领的村庄做了什么。而令人惊奇的是，当时的大多数新闻记者却说：“这一切都会没事的。”因为他们无法理解。没错。这是冷战时期的危言耸听。所以最著名的例子其实是其中一个人，他经常被视为西方关于柬埔寨报道的伟大英雄之一，那就是《纽约时报》驻外记者悉尼·尚贝格（Sydney Schanberg）。我的意思是，他在《纽约时报》历史上发表了一篇最臭名昭著的文章，标题是《没有美国人的印度支那》。对大多数人来说，这是一个更好的生活，声称红色高棉会没事的。
the great heroes of Western reporting of what happened in Cambodia, who is New York Times' correspondent Sidney Schaumb be. I mean, he publishes one of the most infamous pieces in the New York Times' history with the headline, Indochina without Americans. For most, a better life, saying the Khmer Rouge will be fine. Cambodia will be fine. They'll soon be back on their feet. They're a rich agricultural country. They will be revived quite quickly. All this is mad alarmism then about a month or so later
柬埔寨会没事的。他们很快就会重新站起来。他们是一个富裕的农业国。他们会很快复苏。所有这些都是疯狂的危言耸听。然后大约一个月左右后，
he's been the only reporter who's been brave enough the only american reporter brave or foolhardy enough to stay in cambodia so all the rest have fled and then he files another report and he says i was in the french embassy with all the other Westerners. And eventually we were bused to safety in Thailand. And this is what I saw. And he's the man who breaks the story. And he says, unbelievably, the whole of this city has been emptied. So that's three or four million people. Yeah, have been forced to march into the countryside in this sort of,
他是唯一一个有足够勇气留在柬埔寨的记者——唯一一个有勇气或愚蠢到留在柬埔寨的美国记者，所以其他人全都逃跑了。然后他提交了另一份报告，他说：“我和所有其他西方人一起待在法国大使馆里。最终我们乘大巴安全撤到了泰国。这就是我所看到的。”他是打破沉默、报道这一消息的人。他说，难以置信的是，整座城市都被清空了。也就是三四百万人口。
they're like ghosts in a stunned silence, guarded by Khmer Rouge guerrillas. They're being forced out into the countryside, and they are going to be made to become peasants. I mean, this is the story. And they've got no food. They've got no water. And as you said, Tom, the classic thing, people with glasses, people with Western education, people who speak foreign languages,
是的，在一种震惊的沉默中，在红色高棉游击队的监视下，像鬼魂一样被强行驱赶着向乡村行进。他们被强行赶到乡村，将被迫成为农民。我的意思是，这就是事情的经过。他们没有食物。他们没有水。正如你所说，汤姆，最典型的例子：戴眼镜的人、受过西方教育的人、会说外语的人、
people who are well-traveled, they are going to be killed and thrown into mass graves because they are tainted by capitalism and imperialism and so on. So that's a story that we might come back and do a separate episode on. Unbelievably grueling subject. But this is going on and under normal circumstances, this would be the absolute focus of world attention. But actually, it seems to have been pretty much a sideshow.
见多识广的人，都将被杀死并扔进万人坑，因为他们受到了资本主义和帝国主义等的玷污。所以这是一个我们可能会回头再做一期独立节目的故事。这是一个令人难以置信的煎熬的主题。但这一切正在发生，在正常情况下，这本应是世界关注的绝对焦点。但事实上，它似乎基本上只是一个次要的花絮。
Yeah. Because meanwhile, the endgame is being played out in South Vietnam. Yes. So South Vietnam, the southern defences are kind of collapsing all the time. There's a sense of the north can't believe it. You see, they had thought this offensive would take two years, maybe longer. And suddenly, the south's sort of great trap plan has completely fallen apart and they're just going on and the opposition is kind of melting away before them.
是的。因为与此同时，南越的残局正在上演。是的。所以南越的南部防线一直在崩溃。北方甚至对此感到难以置信。你看，他们曾以为这场攻势需要两年，甚至更长时间。而突然之间，南方伟大的防御计划彻底瓦解了，他们长驱直入，而抵抗力量在他们面前如冰雪般消融。
Now, the rainy season is coming probably in May or so. So they need to get this done and dusted within the next kind of few weeks. So the order comes from Hanoi, right, go for it. And I quote, unremitting vigor in the attack all the way to Saigon. So on they go, they take a crucial town, which is basically guarding the main road to Saigon, which is called Swindlock. And it's at that point that President Thieu, who has been in situ all through the Nixon presidency, he's been the face of South Vietnam.
现在，雨季可能在五月左右到来。所以他们需要在接下来的几周内彻底解决战斗。于是河内的命令下达了：好，放手去干吧。我引用原话：“以不间断的猛烈攻势一路直逼西贡。”于是他们继续前进，攻占了一个至关重要的城镇，该镇基本上守卫着通往西贡的主干道，名叫顺禄（Xuan Loc）。正是在那个时候，从尼克松总统在任期间就一直掌权的阮文绍总统——他一直是南越的门面。
He's constantly been badgering the Americans for help. He's been to Washington. He's done the face of South Vietnam. He's constantly been badgering the Americans for help. He's been to Washington. He's done all these kinds of things. He resigns on, I think, the 21st of April, and he gives another extraordinary speech. So he gives this televised speech in which he says, I dug it out this morning, the text. He says, the United States has not respected his promises. It is inhumane. It is not trustworthy. It is irresponsible. The United States did not keep its word.
他不断纠缠美国人寻求援助。他去过华盛顿。他一直是南越的代言人。他不断纠缠美国人寻求援助。他去过华盛顿。他做过所有这些事情。他在4月21日（我想是那天）辞职了，并发表了一篇非同寻常的演讲。所以他发表了一场电视讲话，在讲话中他说——我今天早上把讲稿找出来了。他说：“美国没有遵守其承诺。这是不人道的。它是不值得信赖的。这是不负责任的。美国没有信守诺言。”
Isn't America's word reliable these days? You Americans with your 500,000 soldiers in Vietnam, you were not defeated. You ran away. And then he says, he blames Kissinger personally. I never thought that such a Secretary of State would produce a treaty that would bring us to our death. Doesn't he famously say that it's so easy to be an enemy of the United States, but so difficult to be a friend?
如今美国的话还可靠吗？你们这些在越南有50万士兵的美国人，你们不是被战败的。你们是逃跑了。然后他说——他公开指责基辛格个人。“我从未想过这样一个国务卿会炮制出一份将我们推向死地的条约。”他不是有句名言说：“做美国的敌人很容易，但做美国的朋友却很难”吗？
Yeah. So, I mean, the thing is, President Chu was- And then he ends up in Surrey. Well, I'll tell you why he was in Surrey in a second. He was corrupt. He was autocratic. He was all these things. But he relied completely on US support,
是的。所以，问题是，阮文绍总统——后来他在萨里郡落脚。好吧，我一会儿告诉你们他为什么会在萨里郡。他很腐败。他独裁。他有所有这些毛病。但他完全依赖美国的支援，
and he genuinely believed in the US commitment. And as a Brit, I suppose, American listeners would say, it's easy for you to say. But he wasn't entirely wrong when he said the United States had made a commitment and then had walked away from it. I mean, American listeners will reasonably say, we couldn't just keep pouring troops in forever. But Hugh feels genuinely upset. Now, as you say, he ended up in Surrey. Do you know why he ended up in Surrey, Tom? Is it because he likes golf courses and stockbroker houses?
而且他真心相信美国的承诺。作为英国人，我想美国听众会说：“你们说得倒轻巧。”但当他说美国曾做出承诺随后却背信弃义时，他并非完全错误。我的意思是，美国听众会合情合理地辩解说：“我们不可能永远源源不断地派兵填这个无底洞。”但阮文绍确实感到由衷的沮丧。现在，正如你所说，他最终在萨里郡落脚。你知道他为什么会在萨里郡落脚吗，汤姆？是因为他喜欢高尔夫球场和股票经纪人的房子吗？
I don't know. It's because he wants to visit his son who was at Eton. Of course. Of course. Was he able to continue to afford to pay the school fees? I think he was. Yeah, I think he was. Because he had squirreled out lots of loot.
我不知道。是因为他想去探望在伊顿公学读书的儿子。当然。当然。他还能支付得起学校的学费吗？我想他可以。是的，我想他可以。因为他藏匿了大量的战利品。
Well, he left. Yes, he left with something like, I read he left with something like 18 tons of luggage. Okay. Including gold ingots. It was said to be gold bars. Yeah, it was genuinely said to be gold bars. So there is a slight sense of that. So it's just a couple of days after that that Gerald Ford ford he basically is thinking okay this is now so this is now over so he goes to tulane uh university in new orleans i think it is and he gives a speech where he says the war is finished as far as america is concerned
嗯，他离开时……是的，我看到他离开时带了大约18吨行李。好吧。包括金条。据说确实是金条。是的，确实盛传是金条。所以确实有这种传闻。就在那几天之后，杰拉尔德·福特基本上在想：好吧，这下彻底结束了。于是他去了新奥尔良的杜兰大学，我想是那里，他发表了一场演讲，在演讲中他说，对美国而言，这场战争已经结束了。
and the students all go absolutely wild they're delighted because they think this is the final this is the commitment that we're not going to intervene. Henry Kissinger is actually furious about this. It's a weird thing with Kissinger because at the same time that he's saying, South Vietnam is, I can't do his accent. That was Arnold Schwarzenegger's accent. At the same time that he's saying, South Vietnam is finished. It can't be resuscitated. He's very cross when Ford says, well, we have to give up now. So, okay, the US isn't going to intervene. South Vietnam is clearly doomed. However, what's hanging in the air is what on earth are you going to do about Saigon?
学生们彻底沸腾了，他们欣喜若狂，因为他们认为这是最终的定论——我们不会再进行军事干预了。亨利·基辛格对此愤怒至极。基辛格这人真奇怪，一方面他在说——“南越已经……”我学不出他的口音，那是阿诺德·施瓦辛格的口音。当他在说“南越完了，无法挽救了”的同时，他对福特说“好吧，我们现在必须放弃了”感到非常生气。所以，好吧，美国不会干预。南越显然注定灭亡。然而，悬而未决的问题是，你们究竟打算怎么处理西贡？
So how many Americans are in Saigon? Maybe 6,000. And how many South Vietnamese have the Americans promised to kind of take care of? So it is a Kabul situation, isn't it? It is absolutely Kabul, but on a far grander scale. So don't forget the Americans have been much more committed in South Vietnam than they were in Afghanistan in the last two decades. There have been vast numbers of Americans, enormous quantities of American money, and their commitments are enormous. So 6,000 American citizens, there are probably about 200,000 people who have been employed by American agencies or are married to Americans or are the partners or girlfriends of Americans or the children of Americans, Tom.
那么西贡有多少美国人？也许有6,000人。美国人承诺照顾多少南越人？所以这是一个“喀布尔局势”，对吧？这绝对是喀布尔的翻版，但规模要宏大得多。别忘了，美国人在南越的投入远比过去二十年在阿富汗的投入要深得多。有数量庞大的美国人，海量的美国资金，他们的承诺是巨大的。因此，有6,000名美国公民，可能还有大约20万受雇于美国机构、或与美国人结婚、或作为美国人伴侣或女友、或是美国人孩子的南越人，汤姆。
And who therefore would be absolutely on the hit list of the Viet Cong? Well, that's what the Americans think. So everybody thinks these people could well all be killed when the war ends. We absolutely have to get them out. But if you include the families of those people, right? So imagine you're a translator. You drive a Jeep. You run a bar that American soldiers drank in.
而这些人因此绝对会成为越共的清除目标？嗯，美国人就是这么想的。所以每个人都认为，战争结束时，这些人很可能会全部被杀。我们绝对必须把他们救出去。但是，如果把这些人的家属也算上呢？好吧，假设你是一个翻译。你开一辆吉普车。你经营一家美国士兵光顾过的酒吧。
You run a boarding house. you were a hotel porter you worked at the embassy as a cleaner i mean the list goes on and on but each of those people has a family so actually then when the americans draw up the list they say we're actually talking about a million people i just and you cannot with i mean with all the helicopters in the world you're not going to be able to bring out a million people. Now, the problem they have is the ambassador, who is a man called Graham Martin, who's from North Carolina. He's a liberal guy. He's been involved in the New Deal. He's a sort of career ambassador.
你经营一家寄宿公寓。你是一名酒店门童。你在大使馆当清洁工……我的意思是，名单长得数不过来。但这些人每一个人都有一个家庭。所以，当美国人拟定名单时，他们说，我们实际上谈论的是一百万人。我只是觉得，凭借——我的意思是，就算把全世界的直升机都调来，你也不可能运走一百万人。现在，他们面临的问题是，大使——一个名叫格雷姆·马丁（Graham Martin）的人，来自北卡罗来纳州。他是一个自由派人士。他参与过新政。他是一名职业外交官。
He has completely and utterly gone native. And to use the sort of expression of the time, people refer to him as our man from Saigon rather than our man in Saigon. And he is basically saying, you know, we can't just scuttle and leave all these people. You know, it would be an absolute betrayal. We have to stay and somehow get them all out or, you know, what are we going to do? And so there's this sense of every hour the communist armies were approaching, the kind of tanks are rumbling down the rutted roads and all these people are getting increasingly agitated but how on earth are you going to get them all out and does martin's determination i mean his his sense of obligation to save a million
他已经彻头彻尾地“本土化”了。用当时的说法，人们不叫他“我们在西贡的人”，而称他为“西贡的人”。他基本上在说：“你知道的，我们不能就这样夹着尾巴逃跑，把所有人抛弃。你知道，这绝对是背叛。我们必须留下来，想办法把他们全都撤走，或者，我们该怎么办？”因此，那种共产主义军队一步步逼近的感觉越来越强烈，坦克在颠簸的道路上隆隆作响，所有人都在日益焦虑：究竟怎么才能把他们全都撤走？马丁的坚定——我的意思是，他要拯救一百万的责任感
people who will be you know in the crosshairs does that result in a kind of sense of paralysis yeah of course because henry kissinger is saying, right, make preparations now, shred your documents, get everything ready, sod the Vietnamese, you know, we'll get you in. America first. America first, well, we'll get you, that's all we can do. And Martin just sort of says, no, that won't do at all. We can't run away, we can't leave these people,
命悬一线的人，这种坚持会导致某种瘫痪状态吗？是的，当然会。因为亨利·基辛格在说：“马上下达准备命令，粉碎你的文件，把一切都准备好，管他妈的越南人，我们会把你接出来的。”美国优先。美国优先，好吧，我们会把你接出来的，这已经是我们能做到的极限了。而马丁却说：“不行，这根本行不通。我们不能逃跑，我们不能抛弃这些人，”
and does nothing. And so people are going mad. They're kind of tearing their hair out because all the time they can almost kind of hear the rumbling of the guns on the horizon. And the ambassador is saying, no, we can't do anything precipitous. We can't rush out. Yeah, because you quote him.
然后什么都不做。于是人们快要疯了。他们简直在揪头发，因为他们无时无刻不在地平线上隐约听到枪炮的隆隆声。而大使却说：“不，我们不能采取任何轻率的举动。我们不能仓促撤离。”是的，因为你引用过他的话：
The one thing that would set off violence would be a sudden order for American evacuation. It would be universally interpreted as the most callous betrayal, leaving the Vietnamese to their fate while we send in the Marines to make sure we get all of ours out. So basically, the North Vietnamese army is heading towards Saigon, and Ambassador Martin is refusing to do anything. Pretty much. I mean, that sounds like I'm being very mean to him, but that's certainly the view from Washington. Washington's view is, why is he not doing anything?
“唯一能引发暴力的事，就是突然下达美国撤离的命令。这会被普遍解读为最冷酷无情的背叛，在我们将海军陆战队员派去确保所有美国人安全撤离的同时，却把越南人留下面对他们的命运。”基本上，北越军队正朝着西贡进发，而马丁大使却拒绝采取任何行动。差不多吧。我的意思是，这听起来我对他的评价很刻薄，但这绝对是华盛顿的看法。华盛顿的观点是：他到底在干什么？
Right. This is a terrible, terrible situation. You know, we're approaching the end of April, and we're getting to the point where actually Saigon has not days left, but hours left. And there are still the 6,000 Americans plus a million people who think that they are going to. And the situation I was intrigued to read reminded Kissinger of very much a friend of the show who we've did two episodes on, General Gordon, who ended up in Khartoum, killed by the forces of the Mahdi.
没错。这是一个极其糟糕的局面。你知道，我们正在接近四月底，我们已经到了西贡剩下的不是几天、而是几小时的地步。而那里仍然有6,000名美国人，外加一百万认为自己能被撤走的人。我饶有兴致地读到，这种局势让基辛格想起了本节目的老朋友——我们曾为他做过两期节目的戈登将军（General Gordon），他当年最终在喀土穆被马赫迪的军队杀死。
And I mean, the echoes of British imperial adventures here are very, very strong. And perhaps we could come to maybe in the second episode. So this is what, by the 28th of April? Yeah. That Ford and Kissinger are starting. Well, they didn't. Kissinger has hair.
我的意思是，英国帝国冒险经历的回响在这里非常非常强烈。也许我们可以在第二期节目中再来谈谈这个。所以这是什么时候？到4月28日了吗？是的。福特和基辛格开始……好吧，基辛格有头发。
Ford doesn't have much hair. If Ford had hair, he'd be tearing it out. Yeah, they're going absolutely mad. And, well, Ford says to Kissinger, as tragic as it is, Henry, we've got to leave these people there because they know that all these people, lots of people have now gone to the airport. So there are thousands and thousands of people on the tarmac of the airport waiting for American planes that they think this kind of magic wand is going to be waived.
福特没多少头发。如果福特有头发，他这会儿也该薅光了。是的，他们急疯了。而且，福特对基辛格说：“亨利，尽管这很悲惨，但我们必须把这些人留在那里，因为他们知道所有这些——现在许多人都已经去了机场。机场的停机坪上有成千上万的人，在等待他们以为会出现奇迹的美国飞机。”
And Kissinger and Ford are saying to each other, we have to tell Martin now, no more Vietnamese, Americans only. And Ford says, get the order underway and it sickens me. And Kissinger says, it's the best that could be done done so this is 28th of april so the end is only hours away and yet some of the most sort of melodramatic events and the most sort of tragic drama is yet to come okay so for those iconic moments the choppers heading down to pick up the very last marines people surging over the walls of the american embassy great drama tune in for our next episode second part of this series and we will see you then bye bye bye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
而基辛格和福特互相商量着：“我们现在必须告诉马丁，不要再管越南人了，只要美国人。”福特说：“下达撤离命令吧，这让我感到恶心。”基辛格说：“这是目前能做到的最好的结果了。”所以这是4月28日，结局仅剩数小时之遥，然而一些最具情节剧色彩的事件和最悲惨的戏剧性场面还在后面。好了，至于那些标志性的时刻——直升机俯冲下去接走最后一批海军陆战队员、人群冲过美国大使馆的高墙——精彩好戏，请收听我们的下一期节目，本系列的第二部分，我们到时见。拜拜，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们联手主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐产业的幕后面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前抢购现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。